all right i just saw a new news article
this is what it says
it says broke men are hurting american
women's marriage prospects
there's a shortage there's a devastating
shortage of men
who have their act together according to
a new study
that may not be so surprising to all the
single ladies out there
research now suggests that the reason
for recent years decline in marriage
rate could have something to do with the
lack of economically attractive male
spouses
who can bring home the bacon according
to the paper published by the journal
family marriages
most american women hope to marry but
current shortages of marriageable men
men with a stable job and good income
make this increasingly difficult
it depends how you phrase it i believe
it's not exactly that the problem
the problem is that this doesn't nail
the problem it doesn't
tell you what the issue is really uh and
where or where the issue comes from
i think the standards have changed
because uh
if a woman was not having a job
she would or at least go with a guy that
would
be able to try many jobs or be broke now
that you have women that are able to
work or able to go in the workforce they
the standards have changed
the standard or not the change the same
so they're not gonna go
they're not gonna want this is the date
down video part two
they're not gonna want to date down
they're gonna want someone that has a
stable
uh income because now they know and they
are allowed to do that so
saying that there's a shortest shortage
of good man
i think it's a bit it's a little play on
word it doesn't tell you what the issue
is it's not the shortage of man it's
women that have different standards than
they have before but
that's okay all right so basically one
of the researchers what they did was
they asked the women like what would
your ideal man be and what he looks like
or
what you know how much money makes they
found that women's made-up hubby made 58
more money than the current lineup of
eligible bachelors
okay why should they write this many
young men have today have little to
bring to the marriage bargain especially
as young women's education levels are on
average now exceeding their male suitors
some ladies are even starting to date
down
in order to score a forever partner no
no that's what we wanted
and sure there's a whole love factor in
marriage but in the end it's also
fundamentally an economical transaction
for a lot of ladies
oh look at that it's just interesting
that you know we talk about this kind of
rhetoric and high value man and low
value this but
yo people been saying it they just use
different words dating down dating up
all this other stuff
it's been around we didn't invent those
terms
we talked about at the beginning of the
show and it looked like the fellas had a
lot to say about it
fighting love is not that easy right and
it's especially hard
in this economy and guess what many
women say they are finding it very hard
to find a man
who makes as much as they do a study by
cornell university
found that the country's declining
marriage rate is due to the lack of
financially eligible
bachelors women are actually outpacing
men with education
and this is changing the age-old
mentality that men
are the winners in turn in turn the gig
or small gigs economy
and lack of good jobs out there have
left the ladies single
and disgruntled and researchers say they
are seeing a trend of
women dating down when men do it is with
bread winners
when women do it they're what they're
dating down
okay but she acknowledged she
acknowledged that the fact that it was
wrong and it was probably a joke
so i'm gonna give her that okay
this is just the reality of it so women
you know we're more educated now and i
think that we're furthering our
education so with that being said we're
going to hold off on the baby making
we're going to hold off until we get
that great job
really career driven and i don't think
there's anything wrong with hoping that
there's someone either on your level or
higher than you
so okay nope not a joke
so okay all right go ahead doctor all
right
so before right it was okay when the man
made more money to be the one to buy
everything to do you know treat you and
all this other kind of stuff and now
that you make more money
you can't be that one right you can't be
the one to pay for the meal
and because you're dating down down
down but that's what we wanted that's
not an issue that's what we wanted isn't
this what equality looks like
that's what we wanted that's what we
want that's what that's what we want we
want
women to be able to have a better that's
what i want i want women to have
a better job and people better job
opportunities being paid equally
and stuff like that the thing is when
they reach to that level
they don't want someone that is paid
equally they want to
have someone that has more money that is
weird it's weird out of where it works
doesn't it it's interesting reading that
article the way they speak about men who
don't make a lot of money like they're
garbage
yeah just interesting but but but
anyways
so i would ask this question is it our
fault
force it just that what you want isn't
available to you
so you have to settle for what's out
there
the end of the day if you're making more
money you're more successful more
educated i've said this before and i'll
say it again
that's the choice that you made and now
if you want someone that matches your
income level it's going to be very
difficult to find
if dating somebody who makes less than
you is somehow
dating down i don't know comes down to
the other video we saw
dating down is that how you're going to
refer it like we're beneath you
so when men do it is the norm has been
that man been dating down yep
because when women were not working when
women had less lesser paying jobs
they were men were dating down hey
listen because because at
the end of the day if you were in a
relationship and you were taking care of
the kids
you were a burden a financial burden to
that man because the man was the whole
breadwinner
and stuff like that that man was the
breadwinner that's what happened
that's what that was that's what was
supposed to happen that's what happened
but now
you want it to be equal which is fine
but you want to be equal pay
but you still want people that are
paying
being paid more so the pool of man is
not
lesser is the pool of women that are
successful
that are successful is higher but then
again i guess it's the way you
you see it almost says if you agree with
this kind of rhetoric and design idea
then by definition you also agree with
the kevin samuels mantras
when he talks about high value man all
that stuff you are saying the exact same
thing which is different lingo
and a better packaging it's just it's
the same type of talk
it's fine but it's the same talk this
whole dating down high value man little
it's the same stuff so i just think it's
interesting that like you have this
conversation now but like
yo people have been putting out articles
this month from 2019 we have videos from
2017.
people been talking about low value men
for a long time very commonly all over
all over television forever
yeah for a woman to be able to take care
of the kids she had to go with a
higher volume but now that her value
increases she wants a higher value men
yeah so so you know now on the flip side
someone will play well it's not the
issue that we make more money or this
hat
is that men don't even want to take the
more domestic role or stay at home and
all that stuff
and i would say to that yeah that makes
sense in a lot of cases
a lot of dudes don't want to be at home
they want to be out there working
providing for their family just like
it's not an interest
just like you don't want to be at home
exactly but yeah because he makes less
has to stay at home
he doesn't want to and that's his choice
so if that means that you don't end up
finding a partner who wants to do that
yeah
you know it's like it's not well seen in
our society to be a stay-at-home dad
sorry it's just not am i lying
i don't think you are so when it comes
to that whole dynamic it's a complicated
one and some people might be open to it
but for a lot of people they don't look
at that well me personally i don't care
but
um so just something to keep in mind but
hey
i thought this article was interested i
just want to share with y'all so that's
pretty much it for me
great article sir what do you guys think
is it men's fault that
women came here let us know in the
comments below
[Music]
you